well speaking after her husband resigned
in March as s p chief executive Nicola
sturgeon told our political editor Beth
Rigby that the police investigation
played no part in her quitting as first
minister
it's also an ongoing police
investigation to use of funds we
wouldn't expect you to comment on that
but there's a suggestion you and your
husband will be interviewed have you
heard anything on that but no but I am
not going to comment on I wouldn't
comment on any ongoing police
investigation and I'm not going to
comment on this one so you haven't heard
but
it must have been put pressure on you
and your husband hand on heart did this
play any part in your departure in your
decision
well that was Nicola sturgeon talking to
our political editor Beth Rigby saying
that her stepping down had nothing to do
with any kind of police investigation
let's take you to Scotland correspondent
Connor Gillies who's in Glasgow for us
Connor this is just unfolded in in the
last few hours and Nicola sturgeon in
police custody we know from her
spokesperson that she knew this was
going to happen not all together
a surprise for any of us being who've
been following this story but still
shocking for a former first minister to
be arrested and be held in police
custody questioned over funding and
finances
yeah I think many within the senior SMP
ranks over the course of the last couple
of months have been watching this play
out and thinking it was inevitable that
the former first Minister Nicholas
sturgeon would be the next person to at
least be questioned or asked to present
herself at a police station here in
Scotland to face questions around the
funding and finances of the governing
party the Scottish national party but
that does not make it any less of a
shock this afternoon when that
correspondent dropped from police
Scotland a short while ago that a 52
year old woman the former first Minister
Nicholas sturgeon is now in police
custody is now detained by those
detectives facing questions around the
party that she led for more than 3 000
days the leader of this country for so
long the woman who took the SMP to
continued electoral success no faces
hours of questions by detectives who are
examining what has been going on within
the smp's finances there has been lots
of discussion around 600 000 pounds that
was raised for the purposes of a second
Scottish independence referendum through
crowdfunding suggestions about where
that money is or has indeed gone
suggestions and talk of misappropriation
of such funding clearly though this is a
live active police investigation but
let's just talk through the timeline of
events let's cast our mind back a couple
of months now and the first major big
arrest in this case was the former chief
executive of the SMP a man called Peter
motto Nicholas sturgeon's husband who
was detained faced 12 hours of questions
before being released without charge
then came that arrest of the former
treasurer of the SMP a man called Colin
B2 who he too also faced a barrage of
questions from those police officers
before being released without charge the
third figure Nicholas sturgeon well why
was that potentially predictable well
clearly she was the party leader of the
SMP but she was the third and final name
on the latest audited Financial accounts
of the SMP the other two names were the
other two people arrested Colin Beatty
and her husband Peter Morrow so that
brings us to this Crescendo in this
investigation so far police have 12
hours to question their suspect the
suspect being Nicola sturgeon where they
can then take three further options they
can decide to apply for an extension on
those questions for a further 12 hours
they can release her without charge
pending further inquiry which has been
the course of action so far with the
other suspects here or indeed at that
point they could decide to bring
together some charges so what will
happen in the coming hours who knows but
this is a major moment for UK and
Scottish politics
Scotland correspondent Connor Gillis
thanks very much indeed